One of the things you learned as a clinical psychologist contra the anti
psychiatrists let's say is that diagnosis is often a relief to people.
You know there's a problem with being diagnosed because then you might be
labeled and then the label can follow you for the rest of your life and once
you're labeled as something,
then strange things happen around you that is often reinforced that label.
Maybe you start acting it out more or you adopt it as an identity,
but there's a flip side of that which is that the last thing that you ever want
to hear when you go see a physician or psychologist is,
you know,
I've never seen a case like yours before.
Right?
That is not a relief man because if the messages,
I've never heard anything like what you're telling me,
the outcome is either going to be not so good for you or you're not going to get
listened to it all.
Right.
Because you're such an anomaly that you're,
you're actually in your existence is annoying to the integrated knowledge
structure of the medical professional that you are attempting to receive advice
from.
Well,
it's definitely the case because they didn't,
you know,
if you can be put in a box,
then the box tells the doctor what to do with you.
And that's actually a relief to the doctor,
but also a relief to you.
Right?
Because you want to know,
so you come in,
you say,
look,
I can't go out of my house much anymore.
I'm afraid on elevators.
I have heart palpitations and I sometimes they end up in the emergency room.
Increasingly my,
uh,
interactions in the world are restricted.
I find myself staying at home,
I'm afraid I'm going to die of a heart attack.
And the psychologist says,
well,
you have egg or a phobia.
It's like lots of people have that.
And here's usually how it develops and here's the treatment course and you know,
we can probably do something about that.
And it's like,
well,
you're not going to die of a heart attack now probably.
That's a real relief.
You're not crazy in a completely unique way and you're crazy in a way that might
be treatable,
you know?
And it's so,
it's such a relief because people come in there with a pile of snakes of
indeterminate magnitude,
and they walk out with one manageable snake,
and it's still a snake,
but you know,
one manageable snake beats a hydra right.